Elex follows a very open policy.
Job title does not stop you from moving forward.
This is achieved through the spirit of initiative, passion and professionalism.
I started my relationship with Elex through Clash of Kings.
In which players can create communities
With members of other alliances,
Thereby increasing their strength and expanding Alliance areas.
You can also fight against alliances and other players in different countries.
Clash of Kings is a truly global product
Real-time translation is therefore a very important feature.
We use Google Translate to translate our games.
After players edit their language lists, they automatically show changes.
Then we store the most frequent sentences,
We use it to speed up the translation process.
Clash of Kings is not only available on smartphones but also on tablet devices. </ i>
Through our work on game development, we focus on how to develop the contents of our games
According to brands and styles.
Because Elex is distinguished,
It opposes many of the old trends in game production,
So we learn a lot of new things.
The Android feature is an open, easy-to-access system.
It also allows us to specifically handle customer management
And works very effectively in the management and support of internal games.
The "Ratings and Reviews" function is very useful,
Where we can get useful feedback from game users
This is very important to us.
Elex began its work when we were five students at Beihang University.
We dreamed of exporting Chinese creativity to the world market.
Elex's globalization plans have been summarized primarily in breaking out of the mainland,
And enter the Southeast Asian market.
The cost associated with user acquisition in this region is relatively low.
A large number of these users use Google or the primary Android system
They help us progress in our journey.
The second phase was entering the markets of Europe and the United States.
Google's market share is very large in these two regions,
Including high-value users.
It also has the right resources to help with this type of marketing.
The third stage is the most difficult -
And how to consolidate our foundations in the most difficult markets,
Such as Japan and the Middle East.
We are now in this third phase.
We've collaborated with Google in many ways.
We've launched in-app promotions in many areas to help us increase revenue.
We have also established many gift card events,
Giving players free of charge the same fun as playing for a fee.
This has increased the number of users playing for a fee.
We've worked with Google
For a lot of activities in the weeks and festivals of the games through the Internet and offline,
This has allowed players to learn about other fun aspects of gaming experience
And increased user participation.
Our goal is to become a global gaming company.
So we need to be successful on the basic Android system.
We are working to achieve this in our own way through creative ideas that help us realize our dreams quickly.